SMART development preceded FHIR,
but as FHIR became more significant,
the project shifted to the development of a layer that
builds on the FHIR API and resource definitions.
As we explained earlier,
FHIR provides a set of core data models but many FHIR fields and value sets
may not be constrained to support
specific requirements across varied regions and use cases.
To enable substitutable health apps as well as third party applications services,
SMART implies a set of profiles that provide developers with
expectations about the vocabularies they should use to represent medications,
problems, labs, and other clinical data.
As part of the Argonaut Project we discussed earlier,
the five largest EHR vendors either have a will bill SMART into their products.
The vendors, the SMART team,
and HL7 are working together to standardize the SMART API in HL7 specifications.
Clearly, third party apps must not access
protected health information without being registered into an EHR,
establishing trust in who is using those apps,
and respecting patient privacy choices.
To facilitate this, SMART provides login and data access
authorization models based on the openID Connect and OAuth 2.0 standards.
In this lesson, we will look at how SMART uses these technologies.
Through SMART Genomics and CDS Hooks,
the SMART Project is helping to find the next generation of FHIR base standards for
the clinical use of genomic data and the integration
of clinical decision support into provider workflows.
We will also discuss both of these efforts later.
To make it easier for developers to get started building apps,
the SMART Project offers a set of open source libraries for HTML5,
JavaScript, iOS, and Python.
To support running apps within the EHR's user interface,
SMART allows web apps to run inside browser widgets or inline frames.
It also supports native and mobile apps.
SMART also offers a free web-based API Sandbox that developers can use to test
their apps as well as a locally installable version
the developers can download and run on their own system.
Here is the public Sandbox that everyone has access to,
but you can create your own.
Note that you can install your app and test it
using sample patients, practitioners, and data.
Here for example, is some of the extensive set of
vital signs data that is available for testing.
You can also create patient and practitioner personas
and use them in launch scenarios to test your app.
As illustrated here with a patient,
there are sample personas of both types
available for use if you do not need to build your own.
Note here that you can quickly see what type and
quantity of FHIR resources exist for each patient.
SMART offers FRED, a web-based interactive FHIR
resource editor to help developers create sample data for their apps.
I suggest you try using FRED to build a FHIR resource of your choice.
Here you see that I even put some elements of a FHIR patient resource representing me.
When I click Export JSON,
I get this JSON that corresponds to what I've input.
SMART C3-PRO is a software library that integrates the SMART platform with research kit.
SMART's C3-PRO is a software library
that integrates the SMART platform with research kit.
Apple's open source framework to enable iOS apps to become tools for medical research.
Finally, the SMART site offers extensive documentation.
I strongly recommend you spend time there.